- I explained that these passports,
according to the agent in the booth,
and I don't think he was lying to me,
maybe he was, but I don't think so,
he said to me when I went
to show him my barcode,
he said, "It's okay,
I don't need to see it
"because you just pop up on the screen."
So there's some sort of radius
that they detect all the phones
that have a COVID passport on it.
And yesterday I came across
the border as well again.
I did a quick little run yesterday.
Same thing.
This time I didn't even
volunteer the passport.
They didn't even ask me,
'cause that apparently
links to their system
and all my information
pops up on their screen,
and that's what you guys
are gonna get, as well.
(dramatic music)
- I'm Dave Rubin, and joining
me today is the spokesman
for the Canadian truckers'
Freedom Convoy, a busy man.
BJ Dichter, welcome to the Rubin Report.
- You have no idea how busy,
and I started my day with a car accident,
so, you know, there you go.
- Oh, geez.
Are you all right?
Does it have anything
to do with the convoy?
- I'm great.
I'm gonna need a new
car, unfortunately, so.
But what are you gonna do?
Such is life
- Such is life.
Okay, well, we'll put
that aside for a moment.
First off, where are you right now
and how did you become the spokesman
for this freedom caravan,
or as your prime minister,
Justin Trudeau, calls it,
this group of Islamophobic, transphobic,
antisemitic, crazy people?
- Yes.
I have a good friend from Alberta.
She is a Metis, a very influential
Metis native in Alberta.
She's from Medicine Hat,
and her and some friends
came up with this idea
that you know, we're fed up.
Our economy's crushed, we have no lives.
One of them, Brigitte, was
just about to lose her job,
and they just decided
we gotta do something,
let's do a convoy.
They did one a couple years ago,
and it was small and unfortunately
it didn't do the internal wrangling.
It didn't achieve what it wanted to do,
so they decided this is gonna
be the convoy of all convoys.
So they put the GoFundMe
up and they figured,
well let's get, you know, maybe
we'll get a hundred trucks,
we'll get, like, I don't know, $20,000.
We'll get a little bit of money
and we'll go and have our voices heard.
And Tamara called me I think the day after
they started the GoFundMe,
maybe more or less day
after, maybe two days,
but I think it was the day after.
And she said, "Oh my God, I need help.
"I need help with this."
I'm like, "What's going on?"
She said, "We started this
thing and it's everywhere.
"It's exploding.
"We're already at like,"
I don't know what it was,
a hundred, $200,000, whatever.
And she said, "Can you
come on board and help me?"
'Cause she knows I produce podcasts,
I do messaging and all that sort of stuff.
And I said, "Yeah, sure,
it'd be my pleasure,"
and I also happened to
have a truck, as well.
So it was a perfect fit,
and there we are changing the world.
- So you guys put the GoFundMe up,
and as we speak, is the
go GoFundMe still up?
I thought I had heard something
just in the last hour or so
that maybe it had been taken down
because of a violation of
terms of service or something?
- Oh, that's the usual.
Every three minutes we
get 1,000, 2,000 messages
telling us it's up, it's down,
it's up again, it's down
again, everybody is.
People are unfortunately
a little enthusiastic
and they come up with some
ideas of what's going on.
But right now, as far as I
know, the last I spoke to them,
the funds now are held for review again,
and I'll explain what happened.
The first time, the mainstream,
sorry, the fake news media,
it's not mainstream,
(Dave laughs)
started producing all these stories,
Toronto Star, CBC, Yahoo News,
that our funds were frozen
because of extremists and right wingers
and all that sort of stuff.
And I said to the team, don't respond.
I've used GoFundMe.
I know their protocols.
These are banking regulations.
It always takes seven to
10 days for a new account.
It won't be blocked, trust me.
And so they're going around
building this narrative,
oh, all this speculation of
why it's blocked and it is.
It wasn't blocked, and then
we issued a press releaser
once GoFundMe said,
"Yeah, you're good to go.
"You meet all the criteria."
We sent a press releaser, say,
to all the fake news media.
"We apologize.
"We don't know why you
would release such a story.
"It was never frozen for those reasons.
"It's just a regular protocol,
"and GoFundMe has been
great to work with."
- Wow.
- And that was--
- All right, well, I'm glad to hear that.
For the record, what is the GoFundMe?
Let's actually say it here
so that people can donate.
I know a lot of our audience
has been donating already.
- It's Freedom Convoy 2022.
So if you go there, or you type that
or Freedom Convoy Canada you'll find that.
But what has happened now is now,
it has been frozen again.
- Wow.
- Once we hit-- -
- That seemed too positive a story.
- It was great.
It was great.
Everything was going along.
They were just starting to
do the first e-transfers,
and we did get some money
transferred or whatever,
and then yesterday, last night,
boom, message on the screen,
10 point one million dollars, whatever,
now it's being held for review.
We think what happened,
and this tends to happen a lot
for people who use GoFundMe,
it tends to happen a lot
from the fake news media.
What they'll do is they'll get,
or the leftist politicians,
they'll get an army of
people brigading your account
and just, you know, overload the system,
and then the algorithm triggers,
and then boom, it's being sent for review.
Luckily now,
because there's been so much
international attention,
we have a team of lawyers
and a couple of accountants
that have flown in.
They're on site now in Ottawa.
They came yesterday
and they're now starting the dialogue
working with GoFundMe and
all that sort of stuff.
So I imagine GoFundMe wants
to avoid the PR disaster
of all PR disasters
and will be good to go.
That's what I think.
- Right, all right.
So let's cross our fingers on that.
So in the simplest, in the simplest terms,
now that we've all seen the videos,
I'm covering it every day,
it's starting even to
bubble up a little bit
in mainstream media, although
as you say, fake news media,
it's tough to get these guys
to have to pay attention
to the right things, what
is it that you guys want?
What is the end game for the truckers
and their supporters?
- Simple
End the mandates and the passports.
Now, the reason there's those two things,
the mandates, obviously,
that's the vaccine mandates.
There's certain people who
want it, don't want it.
Freedom of choice.
I'm vaccinated.
Some of people are, some of them aren't,
but it's their choice.
It's not the government's choice to,
you know, it's your body, our choice.
No, that's not how it works here, right?
- [Dave] Apparently.
- The other thing is, the passports,
as I think you saw when I was on "Tucker",
I explained that these passports,
according to the agent in the booth,
and I don't think he was lying to me,
maybe he was, but I don't think so,
he said to me when I went
to show him my barcode,
he said, "It's okay,
I don't need to see it
"because you just pop up on the screen,"
so there's some sort of radius
that they detect all the phones
that have a COVID passport on it.
And yesterday I came across
the border as well again.
I did a quick little run yesterday.
Same thing.
This time I didn't even
volunteer the passport.
They didn't even ask me,
'cause that apparently
links to their system
and all my information
pops up on their screen,
and that's what you guys
are gonna get, as well.
- I mean, it's truly, it's
an episode of "Black Mirror"
with a little bit of "Minority
Reports" and "Total Recall",
a little bit of "The Matrix".
It's all happening right now.
Okay, so the reaction to you guys
from say the people that watch this show
has been pretty positive.
The reaction from Tucker's audience
has been pretty positive,
worldwide, pretty positive.
So I guess I got two on
that, which is number one,
how does it feel to be in
the thick of something?
I mean, Canadians are not
used to being in the thick
of, like, a true cultural
political moment.
I mean, that's number one.
And then number two, do you think
that there's gonna be real
change because of this?
I mean, it seems in the last day,
even though Trudeau's hiding, you know
the premier of Alberta kind of was like,
oh maybe we should give
into some of these demands.
He was sort of like, oh,
I kind of wanted to do it,
but now maybe they'll actually do it.
- How does it feel?
It's quite amazing.
I've told this story a
couple of times to people
that I went behind the
parliament buildings
when I first arrived here.
There's a park behind
the parliament buildings,
and there's a bridge that
crosses over into Quebec,
and I'm sure Viva Frei can expand on this.
There were, it was an army.
I don't wanna use that word.
That means we're violent.
- No.
(laughs)
Right?
There was--
- Quote.
- There was thousands, thousands of people
crossing the bridge into Ontario
with their Quebec flags
and their Canadian flags,
remember, separatism has always
been a problem in Canada,
together and going to meet
their Albertan and prairie truck drivers
and hanging out together,
giving each other hugs.
And, you know, some guys
didn't speak English,
some guys didn't speak French,
but they're trying to figure
out how to talk to each other,
showing each other, you
know, look, this is truck,
this is horn, beep beep.
And, you know, like, it was wonderful.
For the first time in
this country's history,
you got this sense of unity.
And one, you know, Canadians
are not gonna like me saying this,
but one inferiority complex
that we tend to have in Canada
is you do have that unity
of what it is to be an American, right?
And for the first time
I'm seeing that in Canada.
- [Dave] Wow.
- It's absolutely amazing,
so to be in the middle of
that, it's awe-inspiring.
- Are you shocked how ridiculous
the over-the-top attacks have been?
I mean that tweet by Trudeau,
it's like he's got nothing
left, nothing left.
And there was the other tweet from him,
you know, a year ago,
truckers are all heroes,
and now truckers are all the bad guys.
- I'm not surprised in the least.
I actually, before he did
that press conference,
I put on my Twitter, prediction,
Prime Minister Diversity
Blackface is gonna come out
and call us all racist and
bigots and whatever phobes,
and he's gonna publicly shame us.
Why?
Because extremists always double down.
They only have one
strategy, and that's it.
- Where do you see this going
over the next couple days?
I mean, do you think that
they're gonna really turn around
some of this stuff?
Do you think that this gets protracted?
Are you afraid that maybe
they give you an inch?
I mean, this has been
the thing that I've seen
in the last couple days,
where it's like, all right,
the premier of Alberta says,
okay we'll move on some of this stuff.
And then you guys dissipate,
you go back throughout the country,
and then they just ramp
it up again a week later,
knowing that, you know,
you can do this once,
but you probably can't do
it at this level twice.
- Yeah, that's what they tried
with their convoy a couple of years ago,
and they were successful in
basically divide and conquer,
and the politicians got
one faction of their convoy
fighting with another faction,
and then it just fell apart.
And a lot of people from
out west learned that lesson
that we're not gonna
let this happen again.
Personally, I honestly don't see this
going on too much longer.
That's just my, I might be wrong.
The morale on the ground is great.
There's people dancing,
meeting, people falling in love.
Like, it's like a hippie
party, like we become hippies.
- I love it.
- We're playing the videos,
man, with all the music
and they're cleaning up after
themselves and shoveling snow.
It's awesome.
- And so we've had some
communications with the police
because we do have a command
center with ex-military
and a couple of ex-police officers there
ensuring that we have safety protocols,
emergency vehicles have paths
that they can go around things.
Like it's really,
it was really disorganized
when we got here,
'cause we were overwhelmed,
but what the police have indicated to us,
they were monitoring us for several days
and they said, all right,
"You guys have been peaceful.
"You've been great.
"We know all that stuff in
the media are complete lies.
"Keep it up.
"We are not going to act.
"This is now a political issue,
"and the government will deal with you."
The Conservative leader
was forced to resign,
which I had told him a while
ago, I'll get you, and we did.
(Dave laughs)
It was chasing Trudeau off a
cliff, and well, there you go.
So I don't see this going on for too,
at some point Trudeau's gotta realize
all these countries in Europe
have abandoned the mandates.
It's the easiest win in the world for him
to say, you know what?
I, the people, I disagree
with them, but you know what?
The science has changed.
We're gonna follow the
European Union and the UK
and we're gonna remove
all the restrictions.
Will he, I don't know.
- Right, 'cause it's hard
once you've called everybody
a bunch of racist, bigot--
- That's right.
- Homophobes to be like, ah, you know,
but they did have a good point.
You mentioned that the Conservative leader
just got voted out.
So obviously I'm not an
expert in Canadian politics,
but I think I have a decent handle.
And in essence, you guys sort of have
two liberal parties actually.
One of them's just kinda
called the Conservative Party.
They're not very conservative in any way,
but then you have the People's Party,
which Maxime Bernier, who I've had on,
who's been very involved in all of this.
is the more libertarian party.
Do you sense that they could
gain a lot out of this?
And the Conservative
and Liberal party are just
gonna morph into one thing?
Like, do you see a real
reshaping of politics in Canada,
because it's like
freedom or not, pick one?
- I wish that were the case,
but no, and I'll tell you why.
And I know Max personally.
I spoke at his first conference.
The Conservative Party after
Stephen Harper lost decided,
and I met some of those people
and I was in some of
meetings, and they said,
"Well, we're gonna go more center."
And I said, "You wanna go center?
"That's okay."
Like on social issues.
Like, I'm very libertarian socially.
That's great.
That's a good idea, but don't
follow those guys off a cliff.
Well, they did.
So now they have to rediscover their roots
and become actual conservatives.
But there's 45 MPs that
voted to keep Erin O'Toole,
the bald version of Justin Trudeau,
so that's gonna be a problem
internally in the party.
Maxime, but the problem
with the PPC is there's no ground game.
The last two elections I asked him
and I'd asked his other candidates,
I said, "What's your GOTV
strategy?", your get out the vote.
And Max always said,
"Oh, we're gonna do it at the conference.
"We're gonna do it here."
And I asked their candidates,
they have no idea.
So if they're gonna be serious about it,
I think they gotta dial back
the grand standing a little bit
and actually do community
engagement, and they do nothing.
I mean, that's how politics works, right?
You gotta get riding by riding,
and they're doing none of it.
So I dunno.
I think the strategy
that they're using right
now is just gonna lead
to back to the old liberal
versus conservative.
But the question is, will
the Conservative Party
become more center-right?
Will they?
With Candice at the helm, yes,
but she's an interim leader,
and it's frustrating.
The reason I got away
from a lot of this stuff
is because you say to them,
okay, well, take her,
use her an intern leader,
go into an election as soon as possible,
and then if she wins,
then keep her as leader.
But everybody turns into a bureaucrat.
Well, you know, the rules and
the policy guide is she can't.
Like, screw the rules,
amend, use your head,
use your moral will and moral skill.
But they have that inability,
and that's the biggest thing
that destroys that party
in all the years that I've known it.
- To Candice Bergen's credit,
at least she called him
out on the black face
the other day--
- She's great.
- In Parliament, so that was pretty good.
All right, here's the bumper clip.
We're gonna clip this thing
and put it up on social media.
If you had a message--
- No pressure.
- Right now, maybe to Justin
Trudeau and to the world,
it can be two messages,
it can be one message.
Give something that everybody can see
and hear and truly under
what you guys are all about.
- If you're anywhere near Ottawa,
come down to Trudeau's Truckstop
right in front of his
office and his Parliament.
It is all peace and love.
We are gonna solve this together.
It's all unity.
It's a great vibe.
Yes, people are upset.
They want change, and
change is on the horizon
but we're gonna do that
when we stick together
and we be unified and
we don't take the bait
from the leftist activists,
and we got all the time in the world.
We're gonna do it.
And I think once we do, once
we're successful with it,
you're gonna see all the
provinces follow suit.
And that might, I'm hoping,
will have a ripple effect
in the United States
given the amount of support we're getting
from our American brethren
in the trucking industry.
And there's a whole convoy of
American trucks at the border.
I think, it's not Montana,
it's another border.
American trucks draped in Canadian flags.
Would you ever have dreamed
of thinking of that ever happening?
That's the type of unity that
is gonna come out of this,
and we're right on the
crusp of a new golden age,
where we all start to
listen to each other.
- How about that for a positive story
and a grand narrative?
BJ, I wish you guys the best of luck.
Anything I can do for help,
you know where to get me,
and now get out there and
change the world, man.
Thanks.
- All right, brother.
We'll talk to you soon, thanks again.
- If you're looking for more honest
and thoughtful conversations
about international issues
instead of nonstop yelling,
check out our international playlist.
And if you wanna watch full interviews
on a variety of topics, check
out our full episode playlist.
They're all right over here.
And to get notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.